Professor Shelly Kagan:
Last time, I invited you to
think about life on the
experience machine,
where the scientists are busy
stimulating your brain in such a
way as to give you an exact
replica, from the insides of
what it would be like having
identical experiences to the
ones you would have if you were
really doing--well,
whatever it is that's worth
doing.
Climbing the alps,
writing the great American
novel, raising a great family
that loves you,
being creative.
Whatever it is you think is
worth having,
the experience machine gives
you all the experiential side of
those things.
But you're not really doing
You're actually just floating
in the scientist's lab.
And we ask ourselves,
would you want to live a life
on the experience machine?
Would you be happy or would you
be unhappy, to discover that you
actually have been living a life
on the experience machine?
Most of us, when we think about
this, find ourselves wanting to
say, no, we wouldn't want to
have a life on the experience
machine.
I've been discussing this sort
of example for many,
many years.
And there's always a group of
people who think,
yes, life on the experience
machine is perfect as long as
you've got the right tape
playing.
But the vast majority always
says, no, there's something
missing from that life.
It's not the ideal of human
existences;
it's not the best possible life
we can imagine ourselves having.
But that means,
if we think something's
missing, we then have to ask
yourselves, what's missing?
What's wrong with the
experience machine?
The one thing we can conclude
immediately is,
if you think life on the
experience machine is missing
something,
that the hedonist--and views
like hedonism--must be wrong,
insofar as they say that all
that matters for the best
possible life is--for
well-being--is getting the right
kinds of experiences,
getting the right kinds of
mental states.
Because by hypothesis,
the experience machine gets the
mental states right,
get the insides right.
So, if something's missing from
that life, there's more to the
best kind of life than just
having the right mental states,
than just getting the insides
right.
Well, we ask ourselves then,
well, what's missing?
I think different people will
answer that in different ways.
And if we had more time we
could spell out rival theories
of well-being,
which could be interestingly
distinguished one from another
in terms of how they answer the
question,
"What's missing from the
experience machine?"
on the one hand,
and "Why are the things that
are missing from the experience
machine worth having?"
Different theories of
well-being might answer that in
different ways.
Instead of trying to pursue
those alternative theories in a
systematic fashion,
let me just gesture toward some
of the things that seem to be
missing from that kind of life.
Well, first of all,
and most, perhaps,
obviously--if you're just
spending your life floating in
the scientist's lab,
you're not actually
accomplishing anything.
You're not actually getting the
things out of life you thought
you were getting.
You wanted to be climbing the
mountain, but you're not
actually climbing a mountain.
You're just floating there.
You wanted to be writing the
great American novel,
but you're not writing the
great American novel.
You're just floating there.
You wanted to be finding the
cure for cancer,
but you're not actually finding
the cure for cancer.
You wanted to be loved,
but you're not actually loved.
You're just floating there.
Nobody other than the scientist
even knows that you exist.
So, there's a variety of things
you wanted.
You wanted to know your place
in the universe,
but you don't even have that
kind of knowledge either,
because you think you're
writing novels,
finding the cure for cancer,
climbing Mount Everest.
You're completely deceived
about all those things.
So you don't have the kind of
self-knowledge that many of us
value.
Well, as I say,
different theories would try to
systematize these examples in
different ways;
that we don't have any kind of
accomplishments,
we don't have knowledge,
we're not in the right kinds of
loving relationships.
Different theories might have
different explanations as
to--are these things valuable
because we want them,
or do we want them because we
recognize they're valuable?
Rather than trying to pursue
those questions--,
And indeed, trying to work out
the details of these views would
be complicated as well.
Take the example of
accomplishment.
Well, we all think
accomplishment's important,
but it's not as though any old
accomplishment is important.
If somebody sets themselves--or
so it seems to me at least--if
somebody sets theirself the goal
of making the biggest rubber
band ball in the Eastern United
States,
I suppose there's a sense of
the word that that's an
accomplishment if they've got
it,
but it doesn't strike me as the
kind of accomplishment which
makes for a particularly
valuable life.
So, we might have to
distinguish between any old
accomplishment and genuinely
valuable accomplishments.
But again, just put those
details aside.
We can say that there are
certain things that are good
above and beyond
experiences--the right kinds of
accomplishments,
the right kind of knowledge.
After all, not every bit of
knowledge is equally valuable.
It's one thing to know your
place in the universe,
or to know the fundamental laws
of physics.
It's another thing to know what
was the average rainfall in
Bangkok in 1984.
I'm not clear that that kind of
knowledge gives a whole lot of
value to your life.
So, we need the right kinds of
accomplishments and the right
kind of knowledge and the right
kinds of relationships.
But imagine you've worked that
out.
The crucial point is that it
takes more to have the best kind
of life than just getting the
insides right.
It also requires getting the
outsides right--whatever that
comes to--having in your life
not just experiences but the
right kinds of goods or
accomplishments or whatever term
we use for it.
Now, let's say,
instead of pursuing the
questions of how exactly that
theory should go,
notice that if we had that
theory we could still evaluate
in principle--whatever the
practical difficulties might
be--in principle we could still
evaluate rival lives.
We could talk about adding up
all the positive experiences
along with all the--ask yourself
how many goods,
how many accomplishments of the
right sort were in that life?
And that's on the positive side
of the ledger.
And against that we would then
have to subtract the sum total
of the negative experiences,
all the failures and deceptions
or what have you.
Those would count against the
overall value of your life.
We could still say it's--how
good your life is,
is a matter of adding up the
goods and subtracting the bads.
But we would now have a
somewhat broader,
or more encompassing or
inclusive,
list of goods,
and a more broad and
encompassing list of bads--not
just experience,
but also these various other
accomplishments,
whatever exactly that list
comes to.
So, we could still evaluate
rival lives.
My life would've gone better
had I chosen to become a farmer
instead of chosen to become a
doctor.
Or my life would've gone better
for this period of ten years,
but then it would've become
worse.
Or what have you.
Or when we ask ourselves,
how will things go for me over
the next couple of weeks if I go
on vacation versus staying back
here?
We add up the goods,
subtract the bads--whatever our
favorite list is--and we come to
our best educated guess about
the rival evaluations of not
just lives as a whole,
but chunks of lives.
Now, what do those totals come
to?
Well, you might think it's an
empirical question,
and in fact I am inclined to
think it's an empirical
question, varying from person to
person.
But it's worth taking a moment
to flag the fact that there are
people, there are philosophers,
who think we can generalize
across all humans.
You might say that optimists
are people who think that for
everybody in every case,
in every circumstance,
the total is always positive.
"Life's always worth living;
it's always better than
non-existence."
That's what the optimist
thinks--not just for themselves
individually,
but for everybody,
the total is always positive.
Against that,
I suppose, you've got
pessimists--pessimists who say,
"No, no.
Although life perhaps has some
good things, the overall grand
balance is negative for
everybody in every circumstance.
We'd all be better off dead,
or perhaps more accurately
still, all be better off never
having been born in the first
place."
That's what the pessimists say.
And in between the optimists on
the one hand and the pessimists
on the other,
you've got moderates who say,
"It varies.
And for some people the balance
is positive, for some people
perhaps the balance is negative,
whether for their life as a
whole or for certain stretches
of their lives."
We then have to get down to
facts about cases,
try to describe the instance,
perhaps somebody who's in the
terminal stages of some illness
where they're in a great deal of
pain.
And the various other external
goods of life,
they can't--because they're
bedridden,
they can no longer accomplish
things, perhaps their family has
abandoned them.
Whatever the details might be,
we could describe lives and
say, whether or not their life
was good as a whole,
what the future holds out for
them is negative.
That's what the moderates would
say.
It varies from case to case.
Well, however we settle that
issue, notice there's still one
other assumption that all these
positions still have in common.
We've expanded our list of
goods so that--Nobody's going to
deny that among the goods of
life are pleasure and other
positive experiences.
And among the bads of life are
pain and other negative
experiences.
But we've expanded the list of
goods so it includes external
goods and not only experiential
or internal goods.
Still, the views that I've been
sketching all still have the
following assumption in common.
How good it is to be alive is a
matter of adding up all of
the--call it the contents
of life.
Add up your experiences and
your accomplishments and the
particular details of your life
as what the story is about.
It's as though we've been
assuming, and I have been
assuming up to this moment,
that being alive per se has no
value.
It's--life itself is a
container which we fill with
various goods or bads.
And deciding how valuable it
is, how good it is for me to be
alive is a matter of adding up
the value of the contents of the
life.
But the container itself is a
mere container.
It has no value in and of
itself.
We could say that what I've
been presupposing up to this
point is the "neutral container
theory" of the value of life.
Hedonism is a version of the
neutral container theory.
How valuable--how well off you
are, how valuable your life is,
is a function of the contents,
the pleasure and the pain.
We've expanded the list of
goods that can go within
your life, but for all that,
we've still been acting as
though the neutral container
theory is the right approach.
But against this there are
those who think,
no, in addition to thinking
about the value of the content
of life,
we have to remember--so these
people claim--that life itself
is worth having.
There's a benefit to me above
and beyond the question of
what's going on within my
life--am I loved,
am I accomplishing things,
am I having nice experiences or
not?
Above and beyond the question
of the contents of my life,
we have to remember that the
mere fact that I'm alive gives
my life some value.
So, these are "valuable
container" theories.
Now, think about what it would
mean to accept a valuable
container theory.
You're saying that being alive
per se has some positive value.
Well, actually,
the first remark is,
probably wouldn't be completely
accurate to say,
to describe these views as
saying, "It's being alive per
se."
After all, a blade of grass is
alive, and I presume that even
fans of the, what we might call
valuable container theories,
don't think that,
"Oh, wouldn't it be wonderful
if--as long as I was alive in
the way that a blade of grass is
alive."
Life may have value in and of
itself, but it's not mere
life.
What we want is the life of a
human.
We want a life in which we're
accomplishing things,
there's agency,
and the life of knowing things.
Because you have to be a knower
in order to have knowledge.
The life of somebody who can
have an emotional side.
So, it's something like the
life of a person that,
when we say,
when there are people who are
inclined to say,
that being alive per so is
valuable, presumably what they
mean is being alive as a person
per se is valuable.
All right.
Note that point;
keep it in mind.
For simplicity I'll talk about
these views as though they say
life per se is valuable.
Actually, I suppose there could
be a more extreme view still.
It seems implausible to me,
but I suppose it's worth
noticing there are people who
think,
"No, being alive per se,
right--even though there I am
and my brain has been so
thoroughly destroyed that I'm
not longer able to know
anything,
no longer able to relate
emotionally to anybody,
no longer able to accomplish
anything,
there I am in a persistent
vegetative state,
but at least I'm alive."
You can imagine somebody who
has that view.
I've got to say I find that a
pretty implausible view.
So I'm going to restrict
myself, at least when I think
about it, to versions that say,
it's the life of a person per
se that's valuable.
Now, notice that if we accept
this view to decide how well off
I am, or somebody else is,
you can't just add up the
contents of the life.
You can't just add up all the
pleasures and subtract the
pains, or add up all the
accomplishments and subtract the
failures,
or add up all the knowledge and
subtract the ignorance and
deception.
Doing that in terms of the
contents gives you a subtotal,
but that subtotal is no longer
the entire story.
Because we also have to add in,
if we accept a valuable
container theory,
we also have to add in some
extra positive points to take
account of the fact that,
well, at least you're alive or
have the life or a person--or
whatever it is that you think is
valuable in and of itself.
So first we get the content
subtotal;
then we add some extra points
for the mere fact that you're
alive.
Now, notice that since we are
adding extra positive facts,
extra positive points,
for the fact that you're alive,
even if the contents subtotal
is negative, the grand
total could still be positive.
Suppose that being alive per se
is worth plus a hundred points,
just to make up some number.
Even if your content subtotal
was negative ten,
that doesn't mean you're not
better off alive,
because negative ten plus the
extra hundred points for the
mere fact that you're alive is
still going to give you a
positive total,
plus 90.
So, the point of thinking about
the possibility of accepting a
valuable container theory is to
remind us that in deciding are
you better off dead,
has death deprived me of
something good or not,
it's important to not just
focus on the contents but to
also remember to add some
positive points above and beyond
the content subtotal to take
into account the value of the
sheer fact that you're alive.
If you're a fan of the neutral
container theory,
you won't have anything extra
to add, because life per se is
just a zero.
It's strictly a matter of the
contents.
But if you accept a valuable
container theory,
you have to add something more.
And so even if,
you might say,
the way my life is going in
terms of its contents is bad,
being alive per se might still
be a good thing.
Have to add some extra points.
How much extra?
Well, here we're going to have,
of course, more modest and more
bold versions of the valuable
container theory.
Let me just distinguish two
broad types.
What we might call modest
versions of the valuable
container theory say,
although being alive per se is
good,
if the contents of your life
get bad enough,
that can outweigh the value of
being alive so that the grand
total is negative.
Modest container theories,
that is, say there's a
value to being alive,
but it can in principle be
outweighed.
Whether it gets outweighed
easily, or whether it's very,
very difficult and the contents
have to be horrible to outweigh
it,
depends on how much value you
think being alive per se has.
So, those are modest
theories--positive value for
life, but it can be outweighed.
Against that,
you can imagine someone who
thinks being alive per se is so
incredibly valuable that no
matter how horrible the
contents are,
the grand total will always be
positive.
It's as though being alive is
infinitely valuable in
comparison to questions about
the contents.
We could call this the
"fantastic valuable container
theory" as opposed to the
"modest valuable container
theory."
I suppose that label gives away
where I want to come down on
this.
I find the fantastic valuable
container theory fantastic in
the sense of incredible.
I can't bring myself to believe
it, which--I have some
sympathies for valuable
container theories,
but I also have some sympathy
for neutral container theories.
Sometimes I'm drawn toward the
neutral view;
sometimes I'm drawn toward the
thought that being alive per se
is good for you.
But even in those moments when
I'm drawn towards valuable
container theories,
it's always the modest version.
I don't find myself drawn
toward the fantastic version.
Now, if we make these
distinctions,
then again, remembering that
the question we've been asking
ourselves is,
"So why is death bad?"
The deprivation account says,
death is bad for you insofar
as, or it's bad for you when,
by virtue of dying now,
what you've been deprived of
is, another chunk of life that
would've been good for you to
have.
And what we now see is that--to
see whether that could be the
case or not, we've got to get
clear in our own minds about
whether we believe in a neutral
container theory,
a positive, valuable container
theory or--and among those,
between a fantastic and a
modest container theory.
If we are neutralists,
we're going to say,
the question is,
what would the contents of my
life have been,
for the next year,
ten years, whatever?
If that would've been worth
having, then--if the next chunk
of my life would've been worth
having--then it's bad for me
that I die now instead of living
for the next ten years.
On the other hand,
if the balance from here on out
would've been negative,
then it's good for me that I
died now instead of being kept
alive with a life not worth
living.
That's how the neutralists put
it.
If we are valuable
container theorists,
we think the answer has got to
be,
well, look at the contents,
but don't forget to add some
extra points,
even if the next five years for
you would've been,
in terms of the contents,
modestly bad--perhaps the value
of at least being alive at all
outweighs it,
so it still would've been
better for you to be alive.
But if the contents get bad
enough, then you'd be better off
dead.
Notice that on the modest view,
if we ask ourselves,
would it have been good to be
immortal?
the answer's going to depend on
not just whether we accept
Bernard Williams' claim that
immortality would be bad for
you,
because we now realize that
what Williams was talking about
was the contents of an
immortal life.
And that's no longer an
adequate view,
or at least it's no longer a
complete story,
if we are valuable container
theorists.
We could say--you could imagine
somebody saying,
"Oh yes, you're right,
Williams,
the contents get negative,
but that's still outweighed by
the mere fact that you're alive.
So on balance,
being immortal is a good
thing."
Whether that's right or not
depends on just how bad would it
be to be immortal.
Because, of course,
if you're a modest,
if you accept the modest
version of the valuable
container theory,
then if the contents get bad
enough,
that can outweigh the positive
value of life.
Against that,
fans of the fantastic valuable
container theory can say,
it doesn't really matter
whether Williams is right.
Even if being immortal would
become horrendously boring and
tedious or worse,
it doesn't matter.
The value of being alive per se
outweighs that.
So you're always better off
being alive.
So more life would always be
better, no matter how horrible
the contents might be.
So being immortal really would
be a good thing for you.
Death always is a bad
thing.
That's what you can say if you
accept the fantastic container
theory.
I don't find the fantastic
container theory myself--I don't
find it particularly attractive.
I'm inclined to think not only
that--not only that the contents
of life would be bad,
eventually, for all of us if we
were immortal--but that it would
be bad enough to outweigh
whatever value,
whatever positive value being
alive per se may have for us.
So, I'm inclined to think,
eventually immortality would
always be bad overall.
But let me remind you that
saying that does not rule out
the possibility of consistently
going on to say that even though
it's a good thing that we die,
because eventually immortality
would be horrible--for all that,
death could still come too
soon.
It could still be the case that
we die before life has turned
bad.
We die while it's still the
case that living another ten
years or twenty years--or for
that matter five hundred
years--would still or could
still have been good for us.
It's compatible with thinking
that immortality would be bad to
think that in fact death comes
too soon.
But of course,
we now have a return of the
division between moderates,
optimists and pessimists.
You might say,
optimists are those--now in
this more chastened version of
optimism,
optimists say,
"Even if immortality would be
bad eventually after a million
years or ten million years or
what have you,
the next chunk of life would've
been good for all of us."
So that death--they're
optimists in this strange sense,
if they think life would've
been good,
which means of course that
that we die is bad for
us.
Because we all die too soon.
That's what the optimists might
say.
Against that,
the pessimists might say,
"Boy, death comes not a moment
too soon for any of us.
The next chunk of life is
always not worth having,
always worse than nothing."
And in between these two
extremes are the moderates,
who say, "For some of us,
death comes too soon.
For some of us,
death does not come too soon."
There's a quote I want to read.
It's actually out of place now.
I should have read it a lecture
or two ago when I started
talking about immortality,
but I misplaced it.
So, I found it this morning.
So before I just leave the
subject of immortality,
let me conclude with some words
of wisdom from a former Miss USA
contestant.
She was asked the question,
"Would you want to live
forever?"
And she responded,
"I would not live forever,
because we should not live
forever.
Because if we were supposed to
live forever,
then we would live forever.
But we cannot live forever,
which is why I would not live
forever."
Isn't that nice?
All right.
So I've been talking for,
actually now a couple of weeks
I suppose, about the central
badness of death.
Why is it that death is bad for
me?
And the answer I propose is the
deprivation account.
The central bad thing about the
fact that I'm going to die is
the fact that because I'll be
dead I'll be deprived of the
good things in life.
And we've now seen that that's
a bit crude, right?
We have to not talk--just talk
about the good things in the
life, but the good of life
itself,
and we have to notice that
perhaps on certain views,
for certain cases,
it's not really the case that
when I die I'm being deprived of
a good life.
Because the next chunk,
or perhaps from there on out,
it would've been bad.
But still, details and
complications of the sort we've
been considering aside,
the fundamental badness of
death is that it deprives me of
life worth having.
But although I've been at pains
to say this is the
fundamental bad thing
about death,
I think it's arguable that--I
think one could make the case
that this isn't the only bad
thing about death,
even if we're focusing on why
is death bad for me?
There are other features
of death, as we experience it,
that are separable from the
deprivation account,
that at least add to the way
that death occurs for us,
where we then have to ask the
question,
does this add to the badness of
death?
Or conceivably for some of
these things,
perhaps it mitigates it;
it minimizes it in one way or
another.
So, what I want to do is take
at least a couple of minutes and
pursue some of these extra
features as well.
Here's an example.
It's not merely the fact--it's
not merely true that you're
going to die.
It's inevitable that
you're going to die.
There's no avoiding the fact
that you're going to die.
I mean look,
you're all going to college,
but it wasn't inevitable that
you go to college.
Had you chosen not to,
you could've avoided going to
college.
But it doesn't matter what you
choose, you can't avoid dying.
So it's not just merely the
case that in fact we are all
going to die;
it's a necessary truth
that we're all going to die.
So we might ask,
what about this inevitability
of death?
Does that make things worse?
And here I want to distinguish
between the individual question
about the inevitability of
death, and the universal
question.
So just start by thinking about
the fact that it's unavoidable
that you're going to die.
Does the unavoidability of
death make it better or worse?
And the interesting thing is,
I think you can see--you can
get a feel for both possible
answers here.
On the one hand,
you can imagine somebody who
says, "Look, it's bad enough
that I'm going to die,
but the fact that there's
nothing I could do about it just
makes it worse.
It's like adding insult to
injury that I'm powerless in the
face of death.
I cannot escape the Grim Reaper.
This sheer powerlessness about
this central fact about the
nature of my existence is an
extra insult added to the
injury."
Against that,
however, there are those people
who'd want to say,
"No.
Actually, the inevitability of
my death reduces the
badness."
You all know the expression,
"Don't cry over spilt milk."
Right?
That what's done is done.
You can't change it.
What you can't change,
loses--when you focus on the
fact that you can't change it,
it loses some of its grip to
upset you.
Well, if that's right,
and if we then realize that
there's nothing I can do about
the fact that I'm going to die,
then perhaps some of the sting,
some of the bite,
is eliminated.
It's as though you try--try
getting upset about the fact
that two plus two equals four.
Try feeling upset at your
powerlessness to change the fact
that two plus two equals four.
Suppose you wanted two plus two
to equal five.
Can you work up anger and
regret and dismay over that?
Well, most of us,
of course, can't.
Because when we see that
something is just necessary,
we--it reduces the sting of it.
The philosopher Spinoza thought
that if we could only recognize
the fact, what he at least took
to be the fact,
that everything that happens in
life is necessary,
then we'd get a kind of
emotional distance from it;
it would no longer upset us.
We could no longer be
disappointed,
because to be disappointed in
something presupposes that it
could've been some other way.
And Spinoza thought if you see
that it couldn't go any other
way, then you can't be sad about
it.
Well, if we see that our death
is inevitable and we really
internalize that fact,
perhaps that would reduce the
badness of it.
Well, maybe that's right,
but going back to the
firsthand, I don't know how many
of you have read Dostoyevsky's
short novel The Underground
Man.
The Underground Man is upset
about--if I remember
correctly--he's upset about the
fact that two plus two equals
four and there's nothing that he
can do about it.
So he curses existence,
curses God at having made him
so impotent that he can't change
the fact that two plus two
equals four.
And another philosopher,
Descartes, in thinking about
God's omnipotence,
thought that it wouldn't be
good enough if God as omnipotent
couldn't change the facts of
mathematics.
And so he imagines that God,
as omnipotent,
could've made two plus two
equals five.
And so it's a kind of--;So,
it is indeed a fact of our
powerlessness that we're stuck
with the necessities.
God isn't stuck with them.
And so Dostoyevsky takes that
thought and runs with it and
says, "Yeah.
It doesn't help to say that
it's inevitable.
It makes it worse."
Well, there's both sides.
And as I say,
I myself, in different moods,
get pulled in both ways.
What about the fact that not
only is it inevitable that I'm
going to die,
it's inevitable that we're
all going to die.
Does the universality of
death make things better or
worse?
And again, you can sort of feel
the pull both ways.
On the one hand you say,
it's bad that I'm going to die,
but I'm not a monster.
It makes me feel even
worse that everybody else
is stuck dying--or perhaps we
should say dying too soon in
light of our discussion about
immortality.
It's a pity that most
everybody, or perhaps everybody,
dies too soon.
That makes it even worse.
On the other hand,
you know, let's be honest here,
we also know the expression,
"Misery loves company."
And there's at least some
comfort to be had,
isn't there,
in the realization that this
thing isn't just true for me.
It's not like the universe has
singled me out for the
deprivation of dying too soon.
It's something that it does to
everybody.
So perhaps there's some comfort
in the inevitability of death.
Well, here's a different aspect
of death worth thinking about.
What about the
variability of death?
After all, it's not just the
case that we all die.
And I'll stop saying die too
soon.
Let's just suppose we
understand that clause to be
implied in what I'm saying.
It's not just the case that we
all die.
There's a great deal of
variation in how much
life we get.
Some of us make it to the ripe
old age of 80,90 a 100 or more.
Others of us die at 20,
or 15, or 10,
or younger.
Even if death were inevitable,
it wouldn't have to come in
different-sized packages.
That is, it wouldn't have to
have variability.
We could imagine a world in
which everybody dies--everybody
dies at the age of a hundred.
Does it make things worse or
better that there's this kind of
variability?
From the moral point of view,
I suppose, it's fairly
straightforward to suggest it
makes things worse.
After all, most of us are
inclined to think that
inequality is morally
objectionable.
It's bad that,
through no fault of their own,
some people are poor and other
people are rich.
If inequality is morally
objectionable,
then it's very likely we're
going to think it's morally
horrendous that there's this
crucial inequality:
some of us die a the age of 5
while others get to live to 90.
But in keeping with the focus
of our discussion about the
badness of death,
I want to put aside the moral
question and think about how
good or bad for me is it
that there's variability in
death?
Well, we might say,
let's look at it from two basic
perspectives,
those who get less than the
average lifespan and those who
get more than the average
lifespan.
From the point of view of
somebody who gets less,
this is obviously a bad thing.
It's bad enough that I'm going
to die too soon.
I said I wasn't going to keep
saying that remark,
and here I am saying it anyway.
It's bad enough that I'm going
to die.
But what's even worse is I'm
going to get even less than the
average amount of life.
That's clearly an extra-bad.
But we might then wonder,
for every person who gets less
than the average amount of
life--suppose we take the
median,
take the amount of life that's
exactly, 50 percent of the
people get more,
50 percent of the people get
less.
For every person who has less
than the median amount of life,
there's another person who has
more than the median
amount of life.
That person gets to say, hey.
Well, you know,
it's a pity that I'm going to
die or die too soon,
but at least I'm getting more
than the average.
That's a plus.
So perhaps these two aspects
balance themselves out.
There are people who are
basically screwed by the fact
that they get less than the
average amount and people who
are benefited by getting more
than the average amount.
So perhaps in terms of the
individual badness of death
that's a wash.
Maybe.
Except it seems to me it's a
further fact about human
psychology that we care more
about being short-changed than
we do about being,
as we might put it,
overcompensated.
I rather suspect that people
who have less than the average
of something,
it hurts them more than it
benefits the people who have
more than the average of
something.
And if that's right--and that
seems likely to be the case,
especially for something like
death--the extra bad of the fact
that there's variability and so
some people get less than
average--that extra bad,
I suspect, outweighs the extra
benefit of some people having
more than average.
Well, let's consider a
different feature.
We've had inevitability;
we had variability.
What about
unpredictability?
Not only is it inevitable that
you're going to die;
not only do some people live
longer than others,
you don't know how much more
time you've got.
Now, you might think,
well, didn't we already discuss
that when we started thinking
about variability?
But in fact,
logically speaking at least,
variability,
although it's a requirement for
unpredictability,
doesn't guarantee
unpredictability.
You could have variability with
complete predictability.
Imagine that when everybody's
born, on their wrist everybody's
born with a natural birthmark
that indicates the precise year,
day, and time in which they're
going to die.
We could imagine a world like
this where it's inevitable;
everybody's got some date on it.
And for that matter,
there could still be
variability.
Some people live 80 years,
some people live 20 years.
But there's no unpredictability.
Because of the birthmark,
everybody knows exactly how
much longer they've got.
Well, so in our world we don't
have that.
In our world,
not only do we have
variability, we've got
unpredictability.
Does that make things better?
Or does that make things worse?
Would it be better to know when
you were going to die?
Well, one way in which
unpredictability at least has
the potential of making things
worse is this.
Because you don't know how much
more time you've got--You can
make a guess based on
statistics, but as we saw,
there's wild unpredictability.
You can think,
look, "the average lifespan in
the United States is whatever it
is, 82 years.
So I probably have,
you guys are in your 20s--you
know 20--roughly another 60
years are going."
And as you're busy calculating
all this, you're walking across
Chapel Street and you get hit by
a truck and you die.
Right?
Because of unpredictability,
you can't really know.
And because you can't really
know, it's difficult to make the
right kinds of plans.
And in particular,
it's hard to know how to pace
yourself.
You decide to go off to medical
school, become a doctor.
And so not only do you put the
time into college,
you put the time into medical
school,
and you put the time into your
residency and you put your time
into your internship.
And that's a very long
commitment.
It's a long-term plan,
which can go wrong if you get
sick and die in your early 20s.
Well, that's a rather dramatic
example, but the same sort of
thing in principle can happen to
all of us.
You make a life plan,
what you want to accomplish in
your life, and well,
obviously enough,
some of us will die too soon,
not just in terms of,
"oh, well, life still could've
had good things,"
but too soon in terms of you
didn't get where you wanted to
get in terms of your life plan.
If only you'd known you were
only going to have 20 more years
instead of 50 more years,
you would've picked a different
kind of life for yourself.
The unpredictability makes it
worse.
And indeed, less obviously,
it can work the other way as
well.
You make a life plan,
and then, you know,
you don't die yet.
You continue to stick around,
and then your life has this
feeling of--at least we can
imagine this happening--being
sort of anticlimactic.
You peaked too soon.
If only you'd known you had
another 50 years,
that you weren't going to die
young--or James Dean,
going to burn out fast and die
young--if only you'd realized
you were going to live to the
ripe old age of 97,
you would have picked a
different life for yourself.
Now, in thinking about these
points, in effect I'm suggesting
that the value of your life--so
,
we previously were talking
about different theories of
well-being and what makes for
the best kind of life.
Here we have yet another kind
of feature that we haven't
talked about.
We might think of it as,
the overall shape of your life
matters.
What we could also call "the
narrative arc of your life"
matters.
Let me illustrate the point
with some very,
very simple graphs.
These are not meant to be
realistic, but they'll give you
the idea.
So, we all know the Horatio
Alger story right?
Somebody starts out poor and
makes his way through hard work
and dedication and effort to
riches and success.
Rags to riches--that's a
wonderful, inspiring life.
Let's draw the graph of that
life.
So here's how well off you are,
here is time,
and you start with nothing and
you end up incredibly well off.
That's a great life.
That's the Horatio Alger
life--H.A.
Great life.
All right.
Now, consider the following
story.
Here are the axes again.
Instead of the rags to riches
life, imagine the riches to rags
life.
Starts off with everything,
ends up with nothing.
That's the Algers Horatio story.
It's the reverse.
Now, I doubt if there's anybody
here who is indifferent between
the choices, indifferent with
regard to the choice between
these two lives.
I imagine that everybody here
prefers this life.
But notice that in terms of the
contents of the life,
at least the local contents,
it's a bit hard to see why that
would be the case,
right?
We've got equal periods of
suffering and doing slightly
better and slightly better and
slightly better--equal periods
of success and suffering.
For every bad period here
there's a corresponding bad
period here.
For every good period here
there's a corresponding good
period here.
In terms of the contents of
your life, being crude but you
see the point,
in terms of the contents of
your life--equally good.
And even if we accept the
valuable container theory,
and so we say,
"Hah, you know,
being alive per se is worth
something as well."
Well, you're alive for equal
periods of time.
So the extra points get added
either way.
You might say,
look, if we're not indifferent
between these two lives,
that's because we think the
overall shape of your life
matters as well.
The narrative arc, as I put it.
The story "bad to good" is the
kind of story we want for
ourselves, while the story "good
to bad" is the kind of story we
don't want for ourselves.
Interesting question.
Why is that?
And this of course should
remind us of the puzzle about
Lucretius.
Why do we care more about
future non-existence than past
non-existence?
When the bad is behind us,
that seems less bothersome than
when the bad is in front of us.
You may remember the story from
Derek Parfit about having the
painful operation.
Was it going to be in the
future or did it take place
earlier today?
You don't remember.
We're not indifferent.
We want the bad behind us,
not the bad in front of us.
So, whatever the explanation
is, we care about the overall
shape and trajectory of our
life.
Now, that being the case,
we have to worry then that
because of the unpredictability
of death that our lives may not
have the ideal shape.
A lot of us might feel that a
life like this,
where we peak but then we stick
around--you know,
isn't--can at least fail to be
as desirable in which we end
with a bang.
If you start thinking about
narrative arcs--imagine a novel,
right?
It's one thing to have--it's
not to say that the best--if you
want your life to be like the
plot of a great story,
it's not as though you think,
"All right, the dnouement
must occur at the very last
page."
It's okay to stick around for a
while, but if the high point of
the story occurs in chapter 2
and then there are another 67
chapters after that,
you think, this was not a
well-constructed novel.
And insofar as we care about
the overall shape of our lives,
we might worry about wanting it
to have the right shape overall.
Where and when do you want to
peak, as it were,
in terms of your
accomplishments?
Well, that matters to us,
but the trouble is,
without predictability you
don't know where to put the
peak.
Because if you try to aim for
peaking later,
you might not make it to that.
If you put it too soon,
you might stick around for
longer than that,
and then the peak has come too
soon.
All of this suggests then that
the unpredictability of our
death adds an extra negative
element.
It makes it harder to plan what
the best way to live my life
would be.
And from that perspective it
looks as though it would be
better to know how much time
you've got left.
But then we have to ask--so
I'll throw the question out and
we'll call it a day,
start with this next time--then
we have to ask,
would it really be better to
know?
Would you want the birthmark?
Would you want to know exactly
how much time you've got left?
All Right.
See you next time.